Hello, Minky.
Wait, hold on.
I'm trying to figure out where I put my drink.
I'll just leave it where it's at.
Ice monkey drink.
No...
It's milk tea.
Milk... wait.
Milk tea...
Minky...
With ice...
Ice Minky!
Wait!
I think it works!
I'm not reaching, am I?
The prophecy.
I'm not reaching, right?
No.
I could never.
I got my plush into the jar, it goes...
No!
No jar.
Actually, maybe it's for your safety.
Thank you, Burly!
My tapestry came in the mail yesterday.
Teru-pon-one?
I saw that.
Some other people were receiving theirs, too.
Minto, do you know if there will be a restock of merch?
I was able to grab some of it, but a couple things I had my eye on got past me.
No worries if you don't know.
Like... some things?
Like...
Oh...
I think, like, we'll have...
I think...
I know the blocks I don't plan on doing a restock of.
And...
The mugs I might do a restock of.
I think.
You can't reach too far with those short arms, anyway.
What are you talking about?
Welcome back.
Thanks, Pendo!
Thank you, thank you.
What if we held hands on the banana farm?
Wait, I gotta get my dailies.
I was scared, because I got a new computer, right?
Teru-minto tapestry.
Thank you for the gift, Minto.
Of course!
Congrats on winning.
Got my plushie too.
It's so firm and punchable.
It is really firm, though.
It was even firmer before, and I had to say, like, hey, can you soften her up a little bit?
Can you soften her up a little bit?
What was I saying, though?
Uh...
Oh, yeah, I got a new computer not too long ago, right?
And so I had to reinstall the game.
And when I did...
Oh my gosh, so many pops to Murmonkey.
When I did, it made me do the tutorial again, and then also I didn't have my account.
And I was like, oh no!
Where's the cloud save?
But, as you can see, all is well.
Hi, Mintope, you're doing well.
Get Gator.
My friend Aphen says he's investing in sexy Mint stocks.
Oh, I thought you meant... I thought it said socks.
I was like, no, my socks are not for sale.
Stocks.
Are these stocks sold somewhere specifically?
I'm the wolf of Wall Street?
What does that mean, actually?
Wait...
I'm the ghost of Wall Street?
I'm the ghost of Wall Street's past.
It's a movie.
It doesn't have a meaning?
No?
Or...
Welcome back, Mintope.
Thank you, Snow.
No worries, no big deal, by the way.
Welcome back.
Thanks, Brandon.
Just say so.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you.
My oshi, Pat Fusty.
Pat is... Wait, new?
What do you mean, new?
Pat... This is Pat Fusty, everybody.
Kaiju Pat?
Wait, it looks so good.
New skins?
Minky, Minky, Minky, Minky...
Thank you, Pyroboog!
Thank you for the Akadono!
Thank you!
I appreciate it.
If you guys couldn't tell, I switched out the Minky to the Akadono...
Instead.
So the Arigato Arigato to Spongebag is now the 50 and then the Minky is the 100.
Nice aka sound.
Thank you.
Wait, I think I've seen this one before.
Oh my gosh.
Harlequin is such a good name though.
It's so freaking cute.
Octo Jones.
I still like mine the best.
I'm not gonna lie.
Our current Soda skin is pretty great.
Snow.
Hi Minky.
Thank you guys for all the memberships.
Welcome back.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Welcome back, welcome back, welcome back.
Sexy Mint Socks sounds like great merch.
I don't know about that.
My socks however are for sale.
Oh, you heard it here folks.
Ocean Guardian.
Rosalia.
She new?
I've seen these ones.
This one?
Smudge Cat.
Okay.
I like the cat.
Nerd.
Oh my gosh, literal nerd.
Did you just say nerd?
Okay.
Lifeguard.
Brickla.
Sleepy.
Happy birthday to Aru from Blue Archive.
One of my most favorite fail girls ever.
Wait, is it Aru's birthday?
No way.
I love Aru.
She's so silly.
I mean though, I hope you're doing well.
I am.
Thank you.
My name is Minky.
Son of Minky.
Blue Archive Aru is so good.
Okay so, thank you for the 5 gifted Reku.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Gator.
Thanks for the 5 gifted Gator.
So, I have...
My reason for choosing Bloons today is because...
My brain is empty.
Brain's slow.
I had to go to the dealership to get...
Well, I haven't gotten a new boomobile.
For those who don't know, my car broke down.
So, I'm on the hunt.
Or the haunt.
For a new car.
Actually, they loaned me one so I can try it for the night.
And I was driving it around a little bit right before stream.
I think I really like it.
Obviously, I'm not going to say what it is.
Obviously.
But I do like it.
So, yeah, free car.
BMW.
Pool Minky Wheels time.
Let's go.
Finally done with finance.
Year-end money sign.
Finally approved my long weekend vacation.
I can breathe a little.
Thanks for all your content these past three months helped me survive.
Ghost mint!
Is it mint colored?
Oh my gosh.
When I was driving it earlier, I was just like...
I'm going to have to resist probably.
I want an Itasha.
I must resist though.
I must resist the Itasha urge.
Get one with ejection seats.
What is that?
I was just thinking today, oh man, I wonder when Minky will play Bloons again.
Lucky day for you.
Minky, it was my birthday while you were in Japan.
I'll have an exam later today.
Please send me the best of luck.
Meow yellow!
Happy, happy boppy.
And also, good luck with your exams!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, meow yellow.
Meow yellow?
Happy birthday to you.
Boomobile.
Now my boomobile.
Is it possible if you can do co-op?
I don't think I'll do co-op today.
But thanks for asking.
What kind of Itasha would you do?
Probably Blue Archive.
Something about stopping pregnancy.
Oh my gosh, that was Bloons, wasn't it?
That famous clip.
That clip went kind of everywhere.
Now I'm known for that.
I can't believe that was Bloons.
No way.
The ovary map.
Where it all began.
This one!
No!
No way.
I thought that was a toothbrush for a second.
Today, I kind of want to get to like a level 200.
That's my goal.
I'm still recovering from not only just a jet lag.
My battles against the jet hag continue.
But also...
I went to the dealership but that made my brain hurt.
You guys praise me.
I went and I was brave.
Praise me.
Say good job, Minto.
Good job.
You did such a good job.
Good, Minky.
You did so good.
I was so brave.
Yeah, I was really brave.
I didn't let them boss me around.
I was practicing saying no.
They were like, do you want to take this home with you today?
And I said no.
And then they were like, do you want to take it home with you tonight for a loan?
And I said, oh, yeah.
And I was like, is it free?
And they said, no, it's $500 per hour.
No, per mile.
And I was like...
And then they were like, it's a joke.
They had humor.
Thank you so much for the 5 Gets.
Thank you.
Good job, Minky.
Very brave girls.
Thank you.
You're pretty good.
Thank you for all the praise.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, they were jorking it.
I mean, yeah.
No.
Yeah, they were just jorking.
Spank!
Thank you for the 30 gifted!
You changed your profile picture.
I didn't recognize you for a second.
In front of the cars?
Because of the cars.
I do like the one that I have right now.
The loaned one.
I might get it.
I'm gonna try driving it more tomorrow.
And make my decision.
Let's see.
Let's start playing.
I don't know.
I wanna get to level 200, but it's been a while since I've played.
Maybe I take it a little bit easy.
Maybe the frozen one.
A loner.
Yeah, a loner.
Just like me.
Ducky!
Thanks for the 5 Gifts.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Good job, Minky.
Buying a car is super intimidating.
Stay strong, get that B.A.
Itachi route.
No!
I won't get it.
I'll dream about it though.
Hope your car situation shapes up.
Stay, Minky.
Thank you, Shinzulu!
Hot dog.
Resort is good map for getting high levels.
Is it?
Wait.
Resort is...
Wow.
Hashtag ouchie ouch.
Resort.
Oh, this one!
Oh yeah, this is an easy one, huh?
Hello?
Are you an otaku too?
Okay.
I haven't done hard mode.
To get the money money.
Wait, yes I have.
What is this one?
What's the last... I don't have the...
I want the money money.
You like the spooky one?
This one?
Yeah.
I like this map better.
The cabin feels spookier than this one.
This one feels forced, right?
Impoppable and chimps.
Impop... Impoppable.
What's the chimps?
I mean...
It's blooms.
It's nine months.
It has to be died.
No!
I forget these are things.
YouTube never... They never remind me either.
I always forget too.
Impoppable.
Have you considered a surplus Humvee from a government auction site?
Can you imagine just driving that around casually?
Let's go with the medium.
Whole military only.
Reverse!
We get extra money.
What's the sandbox?
I guess we have to do... So reverse...
Means that they just come from the other way.
I feel like it wouldn't make so much of a difference.
We lose this part right here though.
Humvee got stolen recently?
I would drive over other cars if I had that.
I would be like, look out!
Minky incoming!
I'm gonna try reverse.
On some maps it really does and on a lot of maps it's no different.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I feel this one is no different so we'll be fine.
I know Soda goes good here so we'll stick her right in there.
But...
This one I think it's okay to have it reversed.
We'll try.
Today... Today I...
I...
Today...
Today my brain...
Can you guys help me?
Do you guys mind helping me out today?
And then just try not to get too backseated.
But...
Let her cook.
No!
That's the issue.
Don't let me cook.
We missed out on some.
Get him Soda.
Good job.
Yeah, just lay off the caps lock.
Yeah.
You can tell me just don't caps lock.
Not tomorrow.
Today!
Joshua!
Thank you so much for the five gifts.
Today.
Welcome back Minto.
Thank you.
Boy no worky.
I fear that maybe my brain will be broken.
For...
For indefinite.
I will not help.
Okay.
Brain gooder finds.
Thank you.
Actually, no.
You need those more than I do.
Thank you.
Brain is currently running in safe mode.
It's true.
The way she like...
Her head.
She's stretching baby.
She's stretching.
It's also been a minute since I've played Bloons.
So I'm like... Oh gosh.
How do I...
Joshua is like...
For 200 you should get a dark temple.
You need... Wait, I don't even...
Wait, I don't have...
Super monkey.
Wait, I don't have that unlocked.
Magic military primary $40k then upgrade super for...
Is this real?
Place ice monkey.
Got it.
Wait, I can't joke around with that because my... Actually, when I was doing the tutorial earlier...
When I was doing the tutorial earlier... My mouse is having issues yesterday.
If you watch the karaoke...
You'll know that my mouse is having a bit of issues.
And so when I was doing the tutorial it was like placing monkeys in places I didn't want to place them.
Engineer bottom path is pretty broken.
No way.
Engineer... I want the mermonkey.
Oh sorry, my big ol' head.
Mermonkey.
Engineer is this guy, no?
I guess I can place him.
What if I just have engineers all the way lined here?
Let's put him in.
I'm gonna get him some XP, you know?
Counter offer to last guy.
0-0-0 ice monkey.
0-0-0 ice monkey will get us to level 200.
Trust.
40 ice monkeys.
Trust the 0-0-0 ice monkey.
What is that thumbnail?
It's me.
Oh wait, we have quite a bit now.
No?
It's me not having time to create a thumbnail because I had to go to the car dealership.
Friend's birthday and they're a huge fan.
Can you say happy birthday, Maple?
Of course I can.
Aww, you're a nice friend.
Happy birthday, Maple!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Maple.
Happy birthday.
So we're just gonna try and...you know what?
Yeah.
Spend all the money, baby!
Oh, he's so fast.
He's so fast.
He's so fast!
I'm gonna line it up here.
Maximize.
Maximize engineer monkey.
Wait, oh no.
My mouse.
Maximize.
I maximized, but...this guy's just too good.
Actually, too fast.
A little cash to put towards a snake car rub.
A snake car rub!
So everyone in town knows you're cool.
We'll do Octocam on my car.
Thank you guys though, I really appreciate it.
Middle path is the best one.
We can...we can do everything we want to do.
We can.
Someone said that the bottom path is broken though.
I just blindly believe you guys.
Maybe I like you guys too much.
Someone says something and I'm like, I believe you.
This is how I get one guy wrong, maybe.
Thank you so much for the five minutes.
Bottom path gives you money.
Wait, does?
Money, money, baby.
Oh, for this one.
Balloon trap captures balloons until full.
Empty for cash!
This guy though can be the...this path.
Oh, I don't wanna...
Unlock.
Gross!
I don't know if I like that sound.
Bottom path will make you money.
We're gonna be rich, baby, once we...once we get there.
For maximum big snake energy, get a Dodge Viper or Shelby Cobra.
Yeah.
Not to say too much about my car.
Because, you know, some people were saying like, oh, it might be this.
It might...it's probably this issue, but it's not.
And also like, oh, it probably would just be cheaper to, you know, buy or to fix it.
If it's...if that's the problem, then buy a whole new car.
But you guys have to understand that my car...
I already...I already sunk like twelve hundred dollars into it recently for the brakes.
And then the brakes started acting up again.
Like, not even a month later.
And then the windows, they don't really go up and down anymore.
Well, one of them does.
But they're...it's really bad.
And then there's a touch panel on the middle.
And that completely stopped working.
And then there's also the transmission thing that happened.
So, quite honestly, I just...I think it's just better to get a new one.
Yes.
So, yeah.
Yeah, I've been like, kind of just like, you know, dealing with it.
Because it still drove.
And I was like, yeah, you know, I'll still drive it.
Can we upgrade?
No, not yet.
Oh, close, close, close.
This is good, this is good.
So far, we're killing it right now.
Sounds dangerous if the brakes don't work properly.
I'm already dead.
What does it matter to me?
I guess it matters to living people.
Zero...oh, X5, X engineer buffs everyone around by 66.
Oh, well, that's this guy.
We'll be doing this one.
Hopefully we get enough XP for both, no?
Let's see.
Unlock this.
Now we can start making cash money.
Yay!
Rip OL commuter car.
How do I open it?
Ninky Lamborghini!
How's the audio, by the way?
It sounds kind of loud, no?
Crisp.
It's good?
A little loud?
I'll turn it down just a bit.
Oh wait, maybe it's this one.
We'll go back here.
There we go.
Make it louder.
How do I open it?
How do I get my money out?
How do I get...
How do I get the money out?
Wait until it fills.
How do I know when it's full?
Oh, that's how much it sells.
My bushi is back.
Thank you, Iris!
If you upgrade...oh, it exploded.
Nice.
If you upgrade the middle path for your balloon trap, you can trap the target.
The middle...
Like this one.
Well, that's what I'm working on.
We're gonna do these two.
What about this?
Oh, it'll be a lot though.
We're doing our best.
If I can upgrade these guys and then maybe if I have to restart before we get to level 200, it will still be OK maybe.
We'll see.
Yeah, no rush.
We're just vibing.
Nice!
You need to farm.
Oh my gosh, thank you!
I completely forgot about farming.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Let's put it...
Wait...
Who's good...
Was it him that's good around farms?
Who is good around farms?
I recommend unlocking everything and playing optimally at all times!
Druid.
Oh, so it is him.
OK, good, good, good.
So if I put him...
Maybe like here.
Here.
And then we can surround him with farms.
And his is this one, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And then farm.
Farm, baby, farm.
Farm.
Thank you for reminding me about the farm.
OK.
VTuber, why?
What am I doing?
What am I doing wrong?
Everything.
VTuber, you're just so bad at games.
It's hard being as bad as I am.
I'm bad to the bone.
I have no bones.
No bones about it.
Let's go with...
Bananers.
Yummy.
Roxas, thank you for two months in.
Sherry, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
Which would you guys say?
Maybe banana sentrero?
And then...
Wait, this one.
Collects income in radius.
Maybe this one in the middle.
Monkey Wall Street for this one.
And then this one...
The banana sentrero.
Right, maybe?
Bottom auto-collects.
Yeah, bottom auto-collects.
Give me more money.
Bottom is the buy and forget.
Top and middle require micro, but give slightly more money.
I don't mind just being like...
Oh my gosh, Joshua, our Bloons expert.
Thank you.
Thank you for the streaming.
Donated it today.
I'll borrow it.
I'll be okay.
Thank you for being here at the stream.
Tonight I will beat MGS1 for the first time.
I beat... I beat... I beat... I'm sorry.
I beat Vulcan Raven yesterday and got into the room with Metal Gear.
Vulcan Raven, you can do it!
Slimebunny, thanks for the membership.
Okay, farm 2-0-5 is best early game.
5-2-0 is mid game.
Are we mid?
Am I mid?
2-5 is in late game.
The too big to fail?
The monkeynomics?
2-5-0 for farms.
Mid Minto.
Can't wait for Christopher Nolan's next film, Top Hat Minky Goes West.
Wait, I'm so confused.
Okay.
Sorry, brain very slow today.
So, we should do...
Maybe 5-2-0.
Let's just do 5 on this one.
Let's go 5.
And 2.
Increase the value, baby.
Increase the value.
More money, more money.
But also, let's...
Money, money, money.
Oh shoot.
I didn't notice what round we were on.
Everything is fine.
Everything is okay, guys.
Calm down, calm down.
Calm down, it's okay.
All good.
Yeah, not even close.
Don't
panic, don't panic.
We've got this.
I just need a lot more money.
Nice.
I'm like wondering...
I like to also put these guys, the gunner...
The gunner monkeys, like on the edges.
They're pretty good when they're like...
See, look at this placement.
Is that not so good?
Oh my god, he's so snug in there.
He's so good.
Need more sniper monkey.
Sniper monkey.
Is she a pro?
I am.
He's so cozy.
I kind of want to just place him in there because it's so perfect.
No?
I'm gonna.
I'm gonna put him in there.
I like to have him...
The ray of doom.
I don't know how...
Locked and loaded, baby.
There we go.
Need more bows.
I'm working on it.
I'm
working...
Sniper monkey.
Oh yeah, that's true.
The 250 sniper allows for farming.
So true.
We can have those guys.
I like to have my sniper monkeys on vacation.
So I like to put them on the...
On the mats.
What's it called?
Be damned.
Optimization, be damned.
Let's collect some more money a little bit.
So fast.
It's so fast, it's so scary.
Okay, I'm gonna do...
Like I said, I think I'm gonna do the top one.
Or should I do the more...
We can do another one.
My birthday was yesterday.
Thank you so much for the karaoke.
Otel, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Otel.
Happy birthday!
Let's put in some sniper monkeys.
And we're gonna go with...
We'll go with this one and...
We'll go with one and two.
You will be this one.
Shrapnel.
Give me more money.
I do need to upgrade my farm, so...
Let's start upgrading those.
Pro Minto gaming.
Welcome back Minto!
Yesterday was my friend NineLive's birthday.
Can I get a happy birthday from you for him?
Of course!
So many birthdays yesterday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear NineLive.
Happy birthday!
Which one are we doing for this one?
This one is obviously this one.
Maybe we do the increase.
More monkey.
I mean banana.
Oh my goodness.
So fast.
I also gotta upgrade this guy, but for right now he's okay.
Hope you enjoyed your vacation Minto.
I'm not gonna lie, I honestly enjoyed it so much like...
I kind of...
Actually sort of logged off.
Like when I was out and about and doing stuff for the first time...
I felt like I could really kind of turn my brain off and...
I really felt like I was actually like on a vacation.
I wasn't thinking about stuff so much.
It was really nice.
But now my brain is too off.
Now my brain is too off I think.
I'm gonna focus on upgrading these guys that we have, you know?
Because I know it's better to have a strong monkey than a lot monkey.
Did you remember to turn it on?
I don't know how to do it anymore.
Today is my unbirthday.
Happy unbirthday Blake!
He beat my super!
Happy birthday 9!
Happy birthday!
Yay!
Quality over quantity.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Exactly, exactly.
Perfect mental state for bloons.
I might drive some people crazy.
I apologize in advance.
Okay.
We're getting some money.
But I still need... What's the second one here?
Nail gun and sentry shots do extra damage to MOAB.
That might be good.
And you... We can unlock this.
Okay, we're fine.
We're all good.
Wow, thank you for all the memberships!
What the heck?
Thank you guys!
Welcome back!
Welcome back, welcome back.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Welcome home.
Thank you!
Good foam cleanser.
Yeah.
Lots of green.
All of a sudden...
Green is a good color, no?
Green is the best color.
Maybe.
Minto green.
We can move the trap closer to the... Oh, you can?
Wait.
I did not click that.
My mouse is having issues.
Handle it.
MOAB.
Okay.
I really like the spirit of the forest, so I kind of want to save up for that, but...
Let's get the supply drop.
And then I also want to do this one.
Pranked by the exit button.
I know.
Goodness gracious.
The sounds are insane.
Huh?
Am I streamed in?
What happened?
YouTube failing.
It's not me, it must be YouTube.
Limicorn, thanks for the gifted!
Marco, thanks for the gifted!
Thank you so much!
Forgot I had one of these.
Hello, Mickey.
I think it's YouTube, because I don't see any... Usually if something is wrong on my end, it will be through OBS.
But nothing is wrong through OBS, so...
Uh-oh.
YouTube!
Oh, I forgot completely.
What do we want to upgrade this guy to?
Our last banana farm.
Big bobbly boondonkas.
I don't think that's an upgrade.
250.
520.
Middle and top.
Please no spamming!
Please no spamming.
I think we're back.
I wonder what happened.
So strange, YouTube.
So funny.
I'm gonna go with...
Just make one of each.
I don't have a bottom path, I don't think.
Or wait, this one is...
Oh, this is my bottom path.
That's right.
I was gonna say, I do have a bottom path.
Maybe we do 520 then.
Or wait, this one is... Let's do the middle path.
Just give me more money, please.
More money, please!
More money, please.
Nice.
More money.
Oh, we're almost to the end of the round.
Very good.
Supply drop.
Thank you!
Thank you for reminding me.
This one too.
I gotta remember it.
Thank you, thank you.
Yes, please feel free to remind me about supply drop.
And such.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I recently replayed Rayman Origins.
A refiller game.
It's an Xbox 360 PS3 game and Series XS can play it.
When I played it, I forgot the nymphs looked spicy.
Rayman.
I never played Rayman.
I think I always thought he was kind of ugly.
So I just never played it.
Rayman platformers are great, you know?
Sometimes I fall asleep to the sound of balloons popping.
Sounds like rain.
Good night.
Good night!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much for the...
Thank you!
Get my money.
The trap is kind of insane.
Thank you so much for the...
What are we at?
Oh, our XP could be better.
We'll get there eventually.
One day.
One day, I suppose.
What was I going to do?
Oh, this is the banana plantation one.
What's this thing do?
Select a monkey.
I don't know what that just did.
Free play.
Check my bank.
Thank you.
Okay.
What did that do?
Time to ramp it up.
I'm scared.
What does this one do again?
Place bins.
Also increases foam effectiveness.
Let's do the foam effectiveness.
You are this one.
Okay.
I'm gonna start saving for Spirit of the Forest now.
Also so we can get more hearts, you know.
Mickey, I miss you.
Did you...
Were you obsessed with me or something?
You missed me, huh?
When I'm here, it almost feels like she's back from Japan.
She's probably out there holding hands with that yummy sensei.
I wish.
Goodness gracious.
Oh my gosh, so much money!
Holy money!
So much money!
We're gonna be able to give Spirit of the Forest soon.
We're scaling.
Holy money, money, money.
I need to make boats, huh?
I need to make my Merchantman.
It's not like I missed you or anything.
Yeah, yeah.
Get him, Minto.
As the least obsessed Wisp, I can safely say that I missed Minto.
You guys are so silly.
I still have this guy I need to upgrade.
He's just chilling here.
Oh,
we can get the Elite Sniper.
Let's just...
Yeah, let's just finish upgrading him.
Zero, zero, zero, Gunner Monkey.
He's the new meta.
Forget about Ice Monkey.
It's zero, zero, zero, Gunner Monkey now.
Forgotten in the cozy corner.
Yeah, we'll start doing this one.
There we go.
Oh, he's barreling now.
He's barreling now.
I pressed that.
Just keep on going.
I don't like to do the automatic.
Because I like to...
I like to stop and be like...
Do I need to upgrade stuff?
So sorry if you're like...
Please, just do the auto rounds.
I'm just... That's not really my play style.
In the bank, oh yeah.
Collect our money.
Okay.
Wait, what did I miss?
Misses a lot all on her own.
What are you talking about?
Missed disability.
What is happening?
Returned from my first ever Japan trip.
Only took the wrong train once.
Me too.
I also took the wrong train.
I did the Ayaman Cafe on the 10th.
And my friends took me to my first ever Mint Cafe in Akiba.
Wait, where did you go?
And they had a made mint too.
Oh, you went to At Home.
It was the perfect Mito day.
I'm guessing you went to At Home.
Was I correct?
Maybe.
And big O's!
Thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Just a little bit more.
What is this hoarding of cash?
I'm saving up!
Patience.
My dear...
Minky.
There we go.
Yay!
Grow!
Grow.
Let's see.
We'll upgrade the farms after.
That's what we'll aim for now.
Grow.
You should try Ember Ward.
It's a very similar playstyle.
There's a certain upgrade you might recognize.
What does that mean?
New car fund deposit!
Take us on a road trip.
That'll be us tomorrow...
when we play Keep Driving.
Let's see.
What do I want to also do for this guy?
Maybe they'll do the shrapnel shot.
We don't need it though.
We'll do fast.
Fast firing.
Research.
Come on.
Nice.
Shotgun!
Ota!
Thank you.
And we'll upgrade the central market after.
We can also upgrade the lawn.
As I wait for the Shinkansen back to Tokyo from Osaka, the collab cafe hasn't ended yet.
Has it?
No!
It ends Sunday.
I didn't get a chance after Fest, but would love to stop by today or tomorrow.
Yeah, it ends Sunday.
I don't think probably the lines are as bad anymore.
I'm not quite sure to be honest.
If anybody is still in Japan.
I think most people have left or are leaving.
She's killing it.
There we go.
I got the spammer, don't worry.
Let's collect this.
Let's do this.
And then...
We'll work on the cripple MOAB.
That will be our next thing that we do.
Stay strong Minto!
Thanks!
I'm staying strong!
I have a question.
When these are like exploding, these little boxes, am I missing the money?
If I don't hover over it?
Or does it automatically...
Does it automatically do it?
Wait, I'm scared.
I'm working on some things.
What's happening?
Oh, it's fighting something.
What are they fighting?
Oh!
Oh, that's what they're fighting.
It does auto-collect?
Okay, good, good.
Thank you.
Kidai, thank you for 4 months!
Oh my gosh, thank you for the 50 gifted.
Thank you so much!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you!
What is going on today?
I think Bloons honestly attracts like some kids.
It just happens.
You can ignore them.
I'll take care of it.
You guys don't have to worry about it.
Just ignore it.
Wait, this guy we need to...
You!
Cripple!
There we go.
Cripple Moab.
There we go, there we go.
It happens like every time I play Bloons.
It's one of those types of games.
Trial detected.
Alright, this one we're gonna do the long.
So far so good, huh?
What is the one round before level 100 that really filters people?
Which one is it?
I don't remember.
Hamster!
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Thank you.
It's my turn to play Bloons.
96...
Okay, I think I'm thinking of 96.
The fortified DDTs.
Are they?
Maybe.
It's Tuesday.
Still had 100 plus people line up at 2 PM.
Lines are not going away anytime soon.
Someday Mint will realize how many people...
I...
It's a matter of...
I just don't know how many people are in Japan.
I don't know.
You banned a child.
Should we do some more engineer monkeys up here?
Should we really just lay them all out here?
Big ol' engineer monkey parade.
250 spike factory is a good DDT.
Really?
I don't think I have mine upgraded.
Wait, what was it?
2...5...
I think that's what I was working on before.
You can tell.
After you beat game mode, you only...
Yeah, I know you only get the 30% XP.
It's kinda stinky.
There are approximately 124.5 million people in Japan.
And probably like 10 of those people are my fans.
So, yeah.
Okay?
Hermes spikes are better.
We can do all of them.
Oh, but I don't have that one unlocked.
Might as well just put it out there and start having it farmed, no?
Even if it's a little bit of XP.
Every XP maybe will help.
More XP?
Maybe.
What else?
What else do we need to upgrade?
This one, 115.
70,000.
100,000.
We've got our sniper minkies.
This one we can't upgrade.
This one is also 75.
75...
Mink, you can count higher than 10?
How do you know?
How do you know my counting capabilities, huh?
How would you know?
What would you do if you became the most popular Vtuber one day?
Like popular for one day?
Okay.
Same thing I'm doing now.
Check out the XXL trap for engineer.
This one.
I don't have enough though.
I can't.
Huge balloon traps can trap some of the largest balloons.
That sounds so awesome.
I want to unlock it.
Lampy, thanks for the gifted!
Gifted!
Okay, we're almost...
If I became the most popular Vtuber for one day, I would play balloons.
At Minecraft.
Yeah, balloons at Minecraft!
Wait, we're so close to being able to get to 75?
Holy moly.
Checks out.
Yeah.
Let's get a load.
Okay, I have more money now.
So far, not so bad.
I'm gonna go to 90.
Scary.
Okay.
75.
We might have enough for an ice monkey.
I don't know.
Those guys are priceless.
We shouldn't be putting a price on the ice monkey's head, no?
Just enough.
He's our last resort defense guy.
He's crazy.
Holy moly.
I should start doing boats, huh?
Maybe I should have done those a long time ago, actually.
Holy cow.
Wait, what was he at before?
I just clicked on him.
Now he's at 56,000.
What are these guys at?
He's so little!
This engineer monkey.
He has such little stuff.
This one's at 73.
Wait, this guy has been going this whole time, and this guy comes in and immediately gets... Holy cow.
You'd expose more people to Metal Gear.
Oh,
I forgot about my bank!
Oh my gosh, I forgot about my bank!
No!
The big laser is absolutely insane.
It's not even letting anything pass.
It popped almost 100,000 since we've upgraded it.
That's insane.
Since last round!
Holy moly!
The laser is so OP.
Holy cow!
Stealing all the kills for real.
Let's go!
Okay, I believe we'll definitely be able to get to level 100 at least.
I'm still scared for level 200.
But, let's see.
Maybe we can do another one.
It's crazy.
What is this one?
We'll do the monkey wall straight first before we do the other two.
Not just because they're more expensive, but also just because I want it to auto-collect the stuff in the radius so I'm not constantly doing this.
Popped 1% of monkey fanbase.
It's so strong.
It's actually just so strong.
It's crazy.
Holy cow!
Auto-collect, baby.
Woo!
There we go.
We'll be in a little bit of debt.
That's fine.
Get merchants.
Yeah, let's start getting some merchant monkeys in here too.
I said that like 50 rounds ago, didn't I?
Thank you, Dante!
Thank you for 5 months.
Oh my gosh, speaking of Dante.
The...
The Devil May Cry anime trailer!
I was like...
Learner!
I was so excited.
Merchant.
I still have to unlock this.
The Navark of the Seas.
What is a good...
What is a good one for the other round though?
Hotshot?
Hotshot or doubleshot?
Oh, yeah!
Osaka!
From Azumanga.
I did see that.
Middle?
Okay, I believe you.
Hotshot.
I believe you.
Thank you, guys.
Nice.
Let's keep going.
Scary!
Locksmith Wisp here.
Most dealerships are stingy with keys nowadays.
New or used car...
The norm is only getting one key.
Try not to let them rip you off and get charged another 300 to 400 dollars for a second key.
Why so much?
Cripple Moab Sniper feeling neglected.
No!
He's got a good amount of stuff going on.
Check the bank.
Thank you!
So...
What would I...
What would I say?
Oh, the sniper is strong.
Yes, thank you.
Okay, that's a good idea.
Oh wait, what's elite?
What's the difference between elite...
I imagine elite is better, no?
Than strong?
Elite is strong until it gets to the end of the course.
Mix of strong and first.
If balloons get to the end, it switches to first.
Oh...
So maybe sniper...
Cripple Moab sniper on strong and...
This guy on elite.
Maybe?
Hot dog.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, Gary!
You know...
I think you sent the same message twice.
It's just a little backed up, but I see your messages.
Thank you!
The donos are a little backed up.
Kyoki, thank you!
Had your 24-7 karaoke stream on while working to keep you going from insane.
Started watching the summer podcast as well.
Thank you!
Oh my gosh, thank you so much.
I made sure to wash all the dishes like you asked before you left.
Had to use wisp tears.
Oh, you had plenty of water then.
I believe.
I just realized what round we're on.
Not...
Even...
Close.
Not even close.
Endless supply.
I was waiting for so...
Wait, I waited too long for a birthday greeting, but you went on break during my birthday.
Is it too late to ask for one?
No!
Monika!
I'm so sorry.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Monika.
Happy birthday!
This guy...
Oh my gosh, he's actually...
Insano style.
What else should we add?
I feel like we could...
We could get some more monkeys now.
Or maybe I should max these out.
Let's max out the banks and then we'll...
Oh, this too.
There we go.
Okay, next.
Bananas.
I like watching numbers go up.
Have you checked the money?
I have now.
Do I like mint candy?
I do!
I've worked in the auto industry for 11 years.
All new cars come with two keys.
I didn't get a new car.
Well, the one I'm looking at is not a new car though.
It's a used car.
I didn't want to go so much money.
So I didn't get a new.
Thanks for the hotdogs, you guys!
Thank you!
Oh!
Finished my first MGS.
MGS3 on the 3DS!
Oh my gosh, thank goodness for the laser.
Thank goodness for the laser!
So what does this one do again?
I don't even remember.
We're trying to get to 100,000.
Yeah, the laser is kind of...
This is like the perfect spot for the laser.
I might do one on this side too.
Maybe we do another...
Gatling?
Darling?
Oh my gosh!
Darling!
Darling Gunner!
We'll do...
Upgraded to 6 barrel.
Massively increased damage.
Bloons are excluded from existence.
Moab Destroyer.
We could do a 3 of course.
Obviously we could do one right here.
One right here.
Or one right here.
Whatever we so choose.
Which do you guys think?
Row 2 or row 3?
Top left pointing to entrance.
We can't technically point to the entrance though.
Unless like here?
But it would be angled.
2?
Okay, we'll go with 2.
A slight angle.
Mad is an amazing tower.
Is it?
I'm scared though.
Would this really work?
Would this work?
Does it?
It does work?
It does work.
I'm trusting you guys a lot right now.
Wait, did it lock there?
Did it lock?
Yes, it worked.
Okay, 2.
Trust?
Okay.
We're trusting!
I went full loaded!
I went full loaded.
Which one should we do then also?
Because I don't know this...
This setup very well.
250?
Okay.
Trust.
Wow.
I'm trusting!
Aim it a bit above the path.
Okay.
Like here?
Wait, not... I feel like that's too far.
Like there?
Big bullets.
They run into the wall.
What's the goal for today?
200!
Okay, we're getting money, money.
They're running into the wall.
Collect.
What did this do?
We're getting money!
We're so close to be able to do one of these.
Monkeynomics or Banana Central.
Either one.
My bank?
We're okay with the bank right now.
It only has 300 dollars in it.
But I could do more bank.
Oh, oh, oh.
I saw it.
You guys saw it too, right?
The perfect placement.
The perfect...
Oh!
I got it.
You spin it.
What did you guys say That was a good end game.
I assume this is end game though.
I don't know.
End game.
What is end game in this game anyway?
4-2
You guys are the best.
Thank you!
Said no name in other streamers.
So to rephrase my old super chat.
Oh sorry, Influx.
I didn't see it.
Any plans to build Metal Gear Gunpla with other Bishoujo memes while in Japan?
Well, I just got back from Japan.
I'm not really thinking.
I know when I'm going back to Japan next.
But I don't want to think about it right now.
Probably not.
Because I don't know if anybody else likes...
If anybody in Bishoujo likes Metal Gear.
But also...
I feel taking my kit to Japan would be quite big.
Matara?
Is she in Japan?
Is Matara-Kan in Japan?
Though I will be collabing with a Bishoujo member.
Soon-ish.
This month.
That I have not collabed with before.
I'm kind of really nervous about it.
It's gonna be like a big group collab.
That I was invited to.
This month.
Actually, I have so many collabs.
It just happened that way.
Suddenly.
Many big group collabs too and stuff.
I was like...
There's so much happening.
Wait, hold on.
Let me actually open Discord.
Just in case.
I have...
There we go.
Right now we'll stay as we are.
Until I feel...
Banana Central!
Until I feel that we must...
Create more monkeys.
The DDTs are scaring me.
Maybe we create more monkeys.
Monkey.
What does this one...
Isn't the Monkeynomics just gives you...
It's not a loan.
It just gives you money.
Sentry 025.
I actually don't think...
Wait.
Sentry is...
Not engineer.
Is it?
No.
Sentry 025.
I can't do the 5 though.
Look.
It just gives you the 10k.
Hope your trip was good, Mr. Minto.
Thank you, Zornia.
Thank you.
I feel like I should...
Get another monkey and...
Have it like...
Full upgrade and all.
Glue is good?
Glue!
Glue like right here maybe.
Maybe.
Right in the front.
A pirate lord.
We should do that too.
Glue.
Like a super glue.
Alchemist.
Okay.
Let's focus on the glue monkey.
Let's do the super glue.
First and then we can do like...
The pirate and the...
Nice.
Bigger glob.
I'm gonna do the bigger...
025 probably, right?
Yeah, 025.
Thank you.
I'm in Florida today and just picked up...
37,593 pounds of orange juice.
Bound for Pacific Northwest.
Why do you have so much orange juice?
What?
Why do you have so much?
You'll never get scurvy ever again.
Oh my god, the glue is killing it.
Yeah!
Nice.
May I have a glass?
Oh, a truck driver.
I thought...
My initial thought was that you literally handpicked...
That many...
That amount of oranges...
To create the orange juice.
I was like...
No way!
How did you do that?
Why?
Do I have for alchemist monkey?
That's wizard monkey.
Alchemist monkey.
What was it that someone suggested?
I don't think I have enough...
XP for the...
For it though, maybe.
Wait, hold on.
I go up a little.
Ba ba ba ba ba ba ba ba.
I'm looking for...
Top is good.
The permanent brew.
Oh, this is the one that...
Buffs the monkeys, right?
520?
Where would I place him though?
What's up?
He went to his bag.
Thank you!
Thank you so much!
Thank you so much for the silver chat.
I really appreciate it!
Oh, dang it, I clicked it.
I'm saving up money for the Monkeynomics, by the way.
Next to Gloomonkey.
Okay.
Do I still have to pay off this loan?
If I upgrade?
And... upgrade.
Oh, I do.
That's so rude.
Biowm, biowm!
I'm pulling out all the stops right now.
Easy peasy.
Oh, it's my superchat from Astro Bot.
It was so long ago.
Where your nervous laughter silently told us all...
What are you talking about?
Glad you enjoyed your Japan trip.
I wanna make a point to go to Holo Expo next year.
Side note, as a muscular man, which holo fam should I cosplay as?
Anybody with their...
I feel like Marien is a really good muscular cosplay to do, no?
Actually, I got a picture with some of the muscular guys.
Me and my friend group, they were like, we wanna get pics with the muscular men.
But anyone that has their guns out, no?
Looking forward to DMC4 and Peace Walker this week?
Thank you!
Me too.
I'm so excited for both.
Okay, we're doing Alchemist.
No, that's a wizard.
Alchemist.
Should I... Wait, what does...
Target another tower to supercharge the attack.
I don't think we should do that one.
Oh, I should have moved this over, huh?
I'm a dummy-dum.
That's okay though.
Mito stream during my work.
It's not good work!
I was gonna say, maybe I can sneak him here and then maybe another guy right there.
So let's kind of optimize, optimize.
Wait, actually, he should reach the other guys though, nevermind.
Wait, cells?
It's okay, we'll make that money back.
He should reach the other guys, no?
So it might be better to do here, right?
Yes.
I unironically started going to the gym because I wanted to do a buff Mint cosplay.
I wanna see it!
Mito games.
I ran out of snack.
Oh no!
What are you gonna offer to me then?
Going to Japan tomorrow for the first time.
Planning to watch your Akiba tour on the plane.
Any advice?
Steer stage?
Yes, steer stage.
And you can go to the collab cafe.
And...
I made cafes.
Whatever you want.
Thank you!
Thank you so much.
Okay, so we're gonna place him right here.
Yeah.
Place you.
Bam, bam, bam, bam.
What would be better?
Wait, it's 520, right?
520.
520, okay.
Thank you!
We're already at 120.
Let's go.
Okay.
Pirate ship.
Yo-ho, yo-ho.
A pirate's life.
We'll do more merchant ships too, so we can get more money.
More money.
It is so loud.
I'm gonna turn it down a little bit.
My ears are rumbling.
What's a pet sound?
Are there pets in this game?
Ahoy!
Oh, easy.
Wait.
What should be...
What should be the others for the pirate lord?
Sorry, I know I'm asking so many questions.
It's just been so long since I've played.
Oh, for the beast handler!
That's right.
I trust you.
I trust you guys.
I'm trusting you with my afterlife.
Yo-ho, yo-ho.
Pirate's life for me.
Backseaters are thriving today.
Hell yeah!
It's your time to shine!
Backseaters, rejoice!
Bank check!
That's 800 bucks.
Meet those booties.
You'll find my booties in one piece.
Or something like that.
I hope so.
I sure hope my booty is in one piece.
Oh gosh.
Road work ahead.
I sure hope it does.
Yeah, look at this.
We're not making anything.
We're definitely not going to be able to upgrade those guys unfortunately.
What about this one?
Was it any close?
This one might actually be able to get to the carpet of spikes.
That would be insane.
In a one piece swimsuit.
It's all I have!
All I have is a one piece swimsuit.
Gosh, I have a lot of money.
Keyboard mash.
No keyboard mash!
What should we do next you guys?
Everything is fully maxed.
That I can do.
Right?
Oh my gosh.
We're...
We're doing it!
We're playing Bloons!
Ice monkey.
But he has to be 0, 0, 0.
He's on vacation.
2, 0, 5 boomerang.
I don't know if my boomerang is upgraded, is it?
No.
Wait.
2, 0, 5.
It could maybe...
Why wouldn't it let me unlock?
Oh, I have enough.
2, 0, 5.
Is that good?
I don't think I've ever...
I'll try it.
Why not?
We have enough.
Let's do it.
Why not?
Where should I put... I'm gonna put him right here.
Super monkey or monkey... Oh yeah, the plane.
Wait.
2, 0, 5 is alive.
0, 2, 5 is what the...
The hollies?
What's the hollies?
0, 2, 5.
Oh, you can totally see that I literally had it set up for that.
I do 0, 2, 5.
Maybe the initial person meant that.
And they got a little silly.
I'm gonna put him right here.
Nice and snug.
0, 2, 5.
Was that called a thang?
Wait.
Oh, rang.
Oh my gosh.
Boomerang monkey, swing on that thang.
That's what I thought.
Oh no.
A bikini can be a one piece if you just don't wear half of it.
The DDT made it pretty far.
Into the... into here.
It's kinda scary.
Oh, and plane.
Plane monkey.
Is there any place I should put him?
And then we were gonna... I could do...
I could do any of them.
I like plane monkey.
You're a genius.
I don't think so.
I think if I did...
I think if I wore my bathing suit in that particular way...
I would go to jail.
Ice monkey, that funky monkey.
2, 0, 5.
Plane is goaded.
Put a 2, 5, 0 village next to snipers and put the plane next to the village.
Wait, 0... Hold on.
Village?
What was it?
0?
2, 5, 0.
Okay, let's try it.
You guys have such knowledge.
2...
Wait.
I messed up.
No, I didn't.
2, 5...
I thought I messed up for a second.
And then the plane.
Oh, I forgot about the plane.
What's this do?
These guys have...
Sniper monkey is almost to a million.
Sniper monkey is at a million.
Big news.
Plane 2, 0, 5.
Plane.
Like, right here.
2...
0, 5.
Okay, I just need a little bit more money.
But we are making bucks, baby.
We're making money, baby.
This is so exciting.
We're a thriving business.
Do you guys believe in...
Do you believe in love after love?
Do you believe we'll get to 200 today?
Economy is booming.
Bloons are booming.
Donating to meet the bills.
Only one way to find out.
Let's not count our bananas before they drop.
Look at this guy, though.
200 is hard.
I know I'm scared.
I'm not gonna lie.
Have I ever made it to 200 before?
I can't quite remember.
Navark is...
200 stride.
That's the one with the boats, right?
Yeah, unfortunately I don't think we'll get there.
But that's okay.
But also... Hold on.
I'm cooking right now.
If I do a boat right here...
If I do the carrier right here, then we'll have more monkey...
To be able to become Berserker Monkey.
Right?
But what would I put on top?
What would fit on there?
Ice monkey.
No, he's on vacation.
He doesn't need to lift... If this guy has lifted a finger...
Okay, good.
He doesn't need to lift his little paw.
Strawberry banana smoothie.
Yummy!
A cannon on the carrier.
Wait, will it fit?
I guess only one way to find out.
It's top, right?
I want it!
I want it so bad.
Oh my god, I can't even see anything.
Wait, cannon.
Bomb.
Oh my god, it does fit!
It does fit.
Sir Simple Eye, thank you so much for the gifted!
Thank you.
My paws look like this so ice monkeys can look like that.
502 bomb shooter, let's do it.
Five...
Oh no!
Are you serious?
I haven't...
Oh, I cannot... Oh no, I'm so close.
I think we'll be able to get enough.
502.
I think we'll be able to get it eventually there.
I'm so close.
Yeah, we're really, really close.
I'm surprised because I feel like I use the bomb shooters a lot.
Oh, it's the only one that I haven't.
Oh, 520!
Sorry, I have that thing where I read numbers wrong.
I'll just sell it.
We'll take the L.
It's okay.
Five...
What was it?
520.
Okay.
We're gonna get there.
I believe.
I trust.
Minty-lexia.
Give me money.
Welcome to my mansion.
Thank you!
No super monkey?
We could super monkey.
That guy is fun.
Why is it so slow?
My mouse is acting so bizarre recently.
Spam cannons for XP.
For XP!
Does it work in that every monkey on the whole stage gets the same XP?
Or if I have more cannons... How does it work?
Check the farm.
Thank you.
Based on money spent.
I know it barely matters in free play, but we're so close to this, I think we'll be able to get it.
I know it reduces a ton in free play, but we're so close, I feel we could possibly get it.
Whoa, that's so crazy.
You just said that.
Oh, winds of change.
The tarot tapestry I won in your giveaway last month arrived last night.
Now my very ghost can haunt my house!
Thank you!
I want to use your hotdog donut sound as my phone notif.
Do you ever plan on releasing those sound bites in an official way?
I haven't thought about it.
I never thought that people would want it.
Give me money.
Got it, boss.
Maybe we'll just do some more bomb shooters then, huh?
I'm just gonna put one here too.
Why not?
What should we do?
I'm just gonna have him right there for now.
He's just 0, 0, 0.
Bomb, bomb.
0, 5, 2.
Wait, no.
0, sorry.
0, 2.
Wait, I get so confused.
Chatting from Osaka!
Love the cafe.
Thank you, KuriNinja!
So this one is 5, 2.
0.
Oh, 2, 5, 0.
Wait.
2, 5.
Alright, alright.
We spent a lot of money on that one so we better get more XP.
Come on.
Come on, keep working, keep working.
Keep shooting, keep shooting.
Keep popping, keep ballooning.
Come on, strong.
Yeah, thank you.
I always forget to do this.
That I always forget to do the most.
Keep popping, keep popping.
Let's see.
Yeah, the XP.
Oh, see?
It was at 60 before.
We are so close.
We'll be able to get it for sure.
In fact, I'm just gonna add another one.
Like right...
Right here.
I can always tell it later.
This one will be...
0, 2, 5.
Yeah.
There we go.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
Big bugs, big bugs, big bugs, big bugs.
I mean, big bombs, big bombs, big bombs.
This one also wants strong.
You can find the correct build in the back of the CD case.
Good.
How do I say your name?
Smiley, welcome to the bubble shop.
Thank you.
Yeah, I think I am winning so far, maybe.
I think I am winning so far.
Crazy how next month is gonna be the...
Oh my gosh, soul smug.
I was just thinking that.
How next?
Next?
Oh my gosh, like in just a couple weeks?
In three weeks?
In three weeks it will be a whole year since I came back.
Isn't that so crazy?
I got a knowledge point.
Clearly only for in-game.
Your boat doesn't have a grape shot.
Oh, this one?
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm also gonna do another merchant.
I'm like, I'm gonna do another merchant.
So much money.
Maybe actually we'll do the super monkey finally.
I don't think I have a lot upgraded for him.
I don't have so much for him.
I'm scared of the sun temple.
Creed is a turtle.
You could upgrade the last farm.
This one?
No, they're all maxed.
No.
They're all maxed.
I mean, I could make another farm.
The sun temple is scared of you?
I don't think so.
If it was scared of me, it wouldn't eat my monkey.
2-5 for super monkey.
I don't have 5 though.
I have barely any XP.
I think the reason I don't invest in super monkey is because he's so expensive.
And so, I get him late game.
And then by the time I get him late game, I don't have much time to get the experience and all.
Banana central boosts 4-2-0 farms.
Really?
No way.
4-2-0 farms.
Right.
I saw it.
Wait.
There we go.
4-4-2-0.
Nice T-spin.
This guy is fully maxed.
I want... I don't think I've ever made a paragon.
Paragon.
I don't think because I haven't... Never unlocked it.
All my things are not high enough.
This is like the closest one that we have.
But even still, we'll definitely not get it.
Paragon.
I am...
I am my brain.
Dart.
Paragon.
Pinky.
Bloom.
Paragon.
Bomb.
Bloon Master Alchemist.
Oh, that's Boomerang Minky.
Wow, 2 million!
See, I don't even have it all unlocked.
You guys have such good advice and I just can't take it.
I'm sorry.
I can't do it.
I'm useless.
That's an EU VOD watcher.
May I humbly ask...
If you want to be my wife...
Whatever your answer is...
Please keep being cringe and free.
Smiley, I think you are also cringe and free.
I'll keep lurking as long as you exist.
Maybe we should do like a world...
World...
World Wife Minto Day.
Where just for one day I can be your wife.
But I wouldn't be very good at that.
I can't cook.
I can clean.
I don't think you know what you are signing up for when you...
Oh my god.
Did we lose lives?
That was so scary.
There's a chance?
Well, not really.
Guys, I don't think a maid can become a wife.
It's like in the maid code.
What do we use 300k for?
That's a great question.
What should we...
No thanks.
I think we should see other people.
Get out of here, Chovek.
You wouldn't even want to.
I wouldn't even want to.
I'm rejecting you before you reject me.
I'm not fired.
I quit.
World Wife Minto Day definitely checks out with the world...
Wait.
Widespread of urium.
What happened?
I leave and Tia gets a girlfriend.
How did this happen?
Why does something happen every time I leave?
Tia, are you here?
What happened?
It's because you missed the date.
Doesn't that work out better then?
What should we add, guys?
What's the next thing we should do?
Skip the date.
Save the date?
No, skip the date.
What?
Submarine.
Get a temple.
With the super monkey?
The sun temple?
No, it's so scary.
If I go with submarine, submarines scare me.
What else do they do?
They buff, right?
Submarine.
I got
two.
Thank you.
Hold on, I'll read it in a second.
Emma was a maid who became a wife.
Anime can be real.
Emma?
You're seeing other maids?
Who's Emma?
Another maid?
What's wrong with EE?
EE.
Are you the jealous type?
Not even a little.
Emma goes to another cafe minto in Canada.
What?
What were we doing?
I'm not a simp.
Are you saying Rem isn't wife material?
Well, she's not married, is she?
Okay.
Temple?
No!
Two, five... Two, five, O, sub.
Two, five, O, sub.
Two, five.
And also a temple.
No!
I don't want to do a temple!
Top and middle path are both good.
If we did the... Hold on.
Why did I just place him there?
Oh...
I'll just do the top path.
Okay.
I'm getting a little nervous.
I'm not gonna lie about our chances.
Five, O, two, sub.
What is that?
Konbanwa, konbanwa.
I'm gonna say you're a minky.
Oh my gosh, wait.
Wait, you guys are at 11 months.
Scary.
What are we doing for one year back anyway?
I don't know!
Wife day apparently.
It's joke!
I was just jerking it!
What is...
We will do a super monkey though.
I will do him.
Right.
Can he fit in here?
Make room!
Everybody get comfy and cozy.
Maybe here?
Here?
What do you mean?
Do what?
Place him.
On the carrier?
I have no room.
I put the bombs there.
Wait, oh wait.
Let's check.
Why has it like not gone up at all?
Remember it was at 600?
Wait, why hasn't it gone up at all?
It has.
The tiniest bit maybe.
11 months is a typical gestation period for horses.
Is that why they turn into glue?
Because they have such sticky stomachs?
Just jerking it because you can't be anyone's wife.
My penis.
No!
That's why they make a good glue?
Wait, seriously?
They become...
Because their stomachs are so sticky and just chase...
...for 11 months and then they become glue.
No.
Probably.
Someone said put this guy down here.
But he's like so out of the way.
Gestation is birth period?
Oh!
I thought that was...
I'm thinking of...
Is that
not?
Wait.
I was like wow, the food stays in their stomach for 11 months.
Bless your heart.
Don't say that to me.
I know.
I know that when people in the south say bless your heart, they mean that you're stupid.
3-2-0, super monkey.
Okay, Todd Howard, I believe you.
I'm gonna put him right here.
We got a 3.
2-0 him, baby.
Let's go.
Look at him, he's just chilling.
Bless your heart.
No temple.
Temple too spooky.
Never change.
No, I should change.
I should go to the bank right now.
Get some change.
I should.
I should go back to school.
Let's just blame it on the jet lag, okay?
Let's just say...
Jet lag is so crazy right now.
Never change.
It takes like 3 Paragons, 10 plus farms to beat round 200.
Don't say that!
What?
No way.
We're almost just 50 levels away.
MintoBrain404.
MintoSAT, test stream, when?
No, please.
Paragon, Paragon, Paragon.
I don't have a single Paragon.
How do you need so much money though?
Am I not so rich already?
Maybe I'll do more...
What else could I do more of?
Oops, I tried clicking it.
My bad.
No, IceMinky's on vacation!
We're not touching IceMinky!
We're not touching him!
He's on vacation.
It's the third Gallant.
Yeah, you know what?
That's a good idea.
We can put him right down here.
To protect the IceMinky.
Locked and loaded.
And he will become...
This is the second one, right?
Yeah.
So he'll become...
Third.
And also...
Faster?
How much pops for Sniper?
This one has a million.
This one has two million.
Wait, there's a third Sniper pathway that we can do also.
I just realized.
Let's do that too.
Third Sniper.
We'll put him right...
Bottom.
We'll do that one.
This guy looks insane.
For this guy, which would it be?
205?
Or is that for the Sniper?
I got to round 200 before without Paragon, so it is possible.
I also covered the map with monkeys.
I had two Sun Temples.
Oh.
We're gonna have to...
025 for this one.
Let's go.
I believe.
I trust.
What's this one do again?
I lost my mouse.
Oh no!
Thank goodness.
Not a single finger lifted.
Can you upgrade the Spike Factory?
No.
Unfortunately no.
I don't think we'll be able to either.
I'm trying to think of other ones that I have like fully unlocked, you know.
There's the Tac.
Shoot.
No, nevermind.
Not that one.
We could do Dart Monkey.
Top Path Druid.
Oh, the Super Storm is actually so good.
Let's do that and we'll do it like... We'll do him right here.
Or...
I'm trying to think of what's a good place because he'll like start blowing them away, you know.
The knockback is so good.
In the village range?
I feel like he's too far away though for like...
Are there any rules for fan games?
I wanted to make a visual novel about...
Oh, for Game Jam!
Your voice pack inspired me.
Oh my gosh!
No, I don't really have it.
I mean, if you want to make a fan game, that'd be really cool.
Thank you!
Hold on, I also forgot to check my bank.
Nice.
Necromancer.
Oh yes, we can get Necromancer Monkey.
Yeah, we have these also.
We do have these.
And Phoenix Monkey.
We have so many more that we can do to their full potential.
So what I'm gonna do... So for the village...
Let's...
I'm thinking, I'm thinking, I'm thinking...
I'm scared of the temple.
I've never used it before.
Sacrifices enhance and modify the temple's attacks.
Should we just do it?
Should I do it?
Who do I sacrifice?
Get all the wizards.
Okay.
This message is endorsed by President George Sears.
Oh my gosh, Solid Age.
Thank you for 5 months.
Wow, my president is in the chat.
If you do more druids, put them together.
Yeah, that's what I was thinking, right?
Because they enhance each other, no?
I'm gonna put this guy here.
And I could always put a village there.
And we also have this guy.
The more bloons there are, the more damage it does.
Let's just upgrade this guy for right now.
And we'll do...
A heart of oak.
And wrath can also...
Ah...
Rune recommend making a temple from a fresh 300 super.
Don't use one with range boost.
Ah, he's gonna eat stuff.
So, I was gonna ask too, because...
So, everything that the light touches...
He would eat?
Because I was gonna say, do you select what you want sacrificed?
Ah, I see, I see, I see, I see.
I see, I see, I see, I see.
What's poplust?
Oh, oh!
Okay, hold on.
We're gonna try this.
We're gonna add a couple.
So, this guy is gonna go right here.
This guy is gonna go right... We're gonna surround them.
They're gonna have a little party.
Druid party!
This guy can breach him, right?
Oh, these are wizards.
I'm an idiot.
Sorry, hold on.
Being sold!
Sell the monkeys!
My bad, those are wizards.
Okay, redo this guy right here.
Redo this guy right here.
I was just kidding.
Okay, now this guy becomes a wrath.
Wait, he will reach, right?
Oh, yeah!
Big wrath.
Wrath, wrath, wrath.
Poplust, poplust.
Okay, now everything the light touches becomes...
Ice monkey is down here, he's having a vacation.
This thing looks like the... What are the guys in...
Doctor Who.
Hit five poplusts?
Really?
Oh my gosh, such a lust for revenge.
Can they be anywhere?
Daylick.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's just try it.
Wait, what did I just do?
It needs to be extra range.
They are though.
They are as far as they can go.
Daylick.
Yeah, that thing.
Oh yeah, oh yeah baby, oh yeah baby, oh yeah baby.
I can't see anything.
Oh yeah baby, oh yeah baby, oh yeah baby.
Oh yeah.
Dalick.
I didn't even think about the other things for these though.
I guess we'll just...
We'll just enter.
There we go.
Good enough.
Can you build a popping homie?
Oh, I missed my chance.
Why did I use that?
Ice monkey?
He's chilling.
I want him to never lift a finger.
Popping homie.
What's popping homie?
Nothing much, what's popping with you?
Tommy!
Necromancer.
He'll be good around down here probably, no?
Summon the minkies.
Summon minkie, summon minkie, summon minkie.
Summon minkie, summon minkie.
Wait, where can I place it?
Right there?
What is a necromancer?
205?
Say no more.
I believe you.
No more.
He should be close to the front.
Oh, should he?
Oops.
Oh, I can't make another one.
I like your laugh so much.
For some reason, have you guys seen that video of Justin Bieber in an interview?
And the lady laughs.
And he's like, I like that laugh.
I like that laugh.
I thought you were...
I thought you were referencing that.
I was like, oh no, you have a...
It's so funny.
I get a lot of comments though from people being like, gosh, her laugh is so annoying.
Sorry.
Handle it.
Annoyingly cute laugh.
I think it's because sometimes I...
Sometimes I, like, I get too into it.
I get too into it maybe.
It becomes a gross laugh.
It's okay.
It doesn't hurt my feelings or anything.
There's a lot of people that also think my voice is annoying, so...
But it doesn't hurt my feelings or anything.
I just see the comments, you know.
What
do you think for the bitrate?
Is it like craziness right now?
Is it like craziness bitrate right now?
Quinn, welcome to membership.
Thank you.
It's dying?
Oh no.
It's starting to die for me a little.
Oh gosh.
Oh gosh, do you think we'll be able to get the mermonkey after this?
I sure hope so.
I love your laugh so much.
It's cute and definitely funny to see how easily amused you are.
Oh my gosh, I brought this up the other day too.
With some friends when I was in Japan.
Sometimes, like, I just laugh at everything.
And sometimes I get comments from people being like, why is she laughing so much?
What did she take?
What's wrong with her?
Why is she always laughing?
I just think everything is so silly.
I can't help it.
I'm just... I'm just always laughing at stuff.
Everything is so silly and fun.
I like to laugh.
Can we get a nice monkey?
Nice monkey.
Are you cracking up?
I'm really looking forward to cracking up.
That frog bird laugh is my rage tone the whole way.
That's the worst.
The only time I've gotten a comment on a clip of calling you annoying, I went to their channel.
You were stalking them.
They were stalking them.
I went to their channel and they were 12 years old and posted Roblox videos.
That's Barry.
That's Barry's account actually.
That's so funny though.
Maybe the 12 year olds would think I'm annoying, huh?
Oh,
Barry catching strays.
Wow, wow.
It's starting to lag a little bit.
Gosh, this round is long.
160!
One of my favorite Minto laughs is the two more balls.
Speaking of the crane game, literally my Metal Gear Tumblers arrived today.
I got them.
They finally came.
They're a little bit smaller than I expected, but they're a good size.
They're a really good size for cold drinks, I think.
I will be using them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They actually arrived just today.
Good timing.
Two more balls.
Were they worth the money?
They're very cute, I'm not gonna lie.
They're really, really cute.
So I am quite pleased with them.
Should we do any Ninja Monkey?
Let's do a Master Bomber.
What he would be...
Master Bomber right here.
Nice.
Wait, if a Ninja Monkey, what is a good second?
205?
Alright, Huey, I'm trusting you right now.
My birthday was on the second.
I couldn't get a birthday soup then, so I'm doing it now.
Sky!
Oh my goodness, my voice.
Sorry.
Sky, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Sky.
Happy birthday!
I was honestly really hoping that me taking a break would...
Like, you know, going to Japan would help repair my voice a little bit.
But as you can tell, it's still a little rough sometimes.
I wonder... I was thinking, I was like, I feel like I would have to take off like a whole month or something.
To fix it.
But obviously I don't want to do that.
But I feel like if I went to a doctor, they would be like, Missy, you gotta take off a whole month.
You gotta stop talking for a while now.
You're gonna lose it.
You're gonna make lose it.
You need to take off a whole month.
I wonder what this guy's at.
4 million!
You gotta stop yapping.
I feel like, I feel like, I feel like he would say that.
They'd say it just like that too.
They would!
Better you take a month off than having to quit forever.
I felt it really bad yesterday.
During karaoke.
Usually it's not that my throat hurts.
But lately it has been hurting a little bit.
Obviously I don't want to take off a month.
I just can't help...
I can't help how I am.
So I get excitable and then I yell.
And I'm sorry.
I get excitable and I'm like, Woo!
And I yell.
But I really need to take it easy.
Uh oh, I think my chat broke.
Hold on.
Well after this round I'll fix it.
I'll bring you guys back to life for me.
But it's been something on my mind for quite a bit.
Not gonna lie.
It's been on my mind like...
What do I do?
I was never...
You know a lot of Vtubers have this issue, right?
And then finally it's hitting me too.
Pop to us, sabotage that thing.
But we'll see.
Yell more to develop charming rasp.
No!
But yeah, maybe I should go to a doctor.
I think they really will just say, Stop yapping for a bit.
What else would they do?
What else would they tell me to do, you know?
The DDTs are so scary.
I can't see anything that's going on.
No more crash outs.
Doctor's orders.
I know!
I've crashed one too many times.
I've crashed out, I've outed one too many crashes.
I don't know what else they would tell you.
Maybe if you ask the doctor they'd know what...
Maybe if you stopped being such a smartass.
Okay, 164.
Oh shoot.
I think I have a meeting in 30 minutes.
Wait, hold on.
Uh oh.
Uh oh, I think I forgot.
But we're around 200.
Think about it, if you don't do something about it, you're going to sound like Mata.
No!
That'd be the worst.
Actually, some people would probably be like punching the air.
She sounds like Mata.
She sounds like a mommy.
Okay, let's go.
What if we do another plane?
We have like the Sky Shredder.
Let's do that one.
We're Sky Shredding.
And I also have a helicopter.
Oh my gosh, I completely forgot.
Let's do...
205 is only good for...
Oh wait, that's what I have.
Oh, Heli 502 is good in MOAB show.
Okay, so we'll do Heli.
Oh, that's not that.
Come here, you.
Helicopter.
What was it?
502?
502.
PS3 or Xbox?
I think Xbox.
I'm thinking Xbox, probably.
Because last time I did it on PS3.
Xbox, you can still buy the game on the store, you know.
So...
I'm thinking...
Xbox.
Bitrate Shredder.
I'm sorry!
Even I can't tell what's going on.
It's like lagging hardcore too.
It's lagging so hard.
What do I look like right now?
There we go.
That's better, no?
I'll protect you!
I'll protect you from the bitrate.
The balloons are popping.
There's lots of balloons happening right now.
Nothing else is happening.
It's kind of boring.
Stonks are up.
And such.
Look into my eyes, Minto.
No, you look into my eyes.
Are you gonna watch the DMC anime?
Not the Netflix one too, after finishing 4?
Maybe.
I might wait until I finish the series though.
If bunny girl, why no opai?
Because not all girls have big opai.
That's okay.
Send out the guns!
Guns!
Oh my god, the game is freezing.
Oh my god, the game is freezing real.
My screen!
Is there anything that I can upgrade?
Oh, this one.
Let's see.
I don't think this one matters very much.
We'll do the exploding I suppose.
Any size is a prize.
So... true.
The true challenge of getting to 200 is the game not crashing.
Don't forget the meaning.
Don't worry, I'm noticing the time.
Thank you though.
All good.
Maybe.
Is there anything out of...
This!
We finally got the bomb shooter!
We finally got the balloon crush!
This one right?
Yeah!
Oh my gosh, finally.
It happened!
He's not even doing anything.
Is he?
Oh, there he goes.
Nice.
Nice!
Guys, we only have 30 rounds left.
Oh, the pineapples.
That's what they do.
Oh, it's kind of weird.
I don't like it.
Hmm...
The super bunky?
He only has 45,000.
What's the longest we made it to?
I don't remember to be honest.
I feel like it was like 180 something.
I feel.
Snipers?
My snipers are all here.
I deploy everything we have.
Oh gosh.
Deploy everything!
Why are they getting stronger?
Okay, maybe we are okay.
Maybe we are okay.
Such chaos.
Laser save us.
It's okay.
It's like they always say.
When you are in for a penny...
Maybe a mortar monkey, but he doesn't have...
I have him so upgraded, you know.
I'm trying to think of who else.
Maybe grandmaster ninja monkey.
We'll just get as many towers as we can.
And that like...
That can...
What's the word?
Do anything.
That can upgrade to their full potential.
Grand saboteur monkey.
I can't unlock it though.
I don't have it yet.
Glue storm.
That's a good idea too.
Good idea.
I'm just gonna put him...
Glue storm.
Nice.
Glue storm will eat the frames.
We have to do it though.
We have to do it.
Wait, you can lower the projectile size?
No way.
How do you do that?
I don't see it.
I'm getting one guy maybe.
Oh, accessibility.
Oh my god!
It looks like...
Oh my god, there are four ants!
Oh my god!
Everything is so tiny!
That's so funny.
It doesn't make the bloons tiny though, right?
I still need to see those.
I need to see those.
Hold on, I'm gonna make it a little bit bigger.
Like 30...
Thank you percent.
They look just like you.
Stop!
Why am I catching strays?
Oh no, okay, they're good size.
They're good size.
It's perfect.
Oh, I hate actually how this looks.
Maybe I don't like how that looks.
Hold on.
Sorry, I'm gonna make it smaller again.
25 percent.
Okay.
Nice.
It looks like nothing is happening on the screen now.
And it's kind of stressing me out.
It's so small.
It looks like we're not even firing at them.
I'm scared.
173.
Okay.
173, you guys.
Make it zero, then panic.
No!
The laser is gone!
I don't like it.
I can barely see the...
The supply drop.
Guys, I think we're gonna make it to a million bucks.
We're gonna make it to so much money.
Even the weeds are tiny.
I know, the thorns are so small.
It's so funny.
I'm gonna be a millionaire.
Just like the TV show.
Wall Street should auto-collect the supply drop.
I don't think it does, no?
Let's see.
Oh, it does!
You're so right!
I was a fool!
Wow.
I was a fool.
Anything else we should add, everybody?
I mean, I know there should be things we should add.
I just don't know what.
Check the bank?
Oh, I have not checked the bank in a long time.
Helicopter?
Come on.
No!
Oh, yeah.
This one is Apache.
So we'll do this one as...
Oh, we only have Apache on the...
We'll do the Moab shove.
And...
Pursuit, maybe?
I like Pursuit.
I like how it doesn't flashbang me anymore.
It's kinda nice.
Push!
Oh, it collects it.
I forgot.
Alright.
I think we're alright.
I think we got this.
We're fortified.
Oh my gosh.
The necromancer balloons are tiny too.
Oh, we got the phoenix too.
We can do the phoenix.
Wizard monkey.
Where should he go though?
If I put him around here, will he be buffed?
Yes.
And...
Maybe...
Arcane blast?
Chihuahua.
What other... What's the last wizard?
Arc mage.
Let's get him too.
Also, wait.
Not first.
Strong.
I'm pressing everything.
I'm pressing...
Blue blast!
Oh my gosh.
Everything is moving so slowly.
You got this game!
You got this!
I think we're okay, maybe.
I think we're okay.
Oh, why did I do that?
I'm such an idiot.
No!
I didn't mean to.
I got ahead of myself.
Actually, maybe it's fine.
This guy's got no balloons.
I think I put him in a bad spot.
Maybe I should sell him and...
I wish I could re-home him.
I wish I could... There's a tower, right?
That allows you to move the minkis.
Check the bank.
I think it's okay.
Yeah, it's only at 800.
0-4-0.
Heli can move.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well, I have a lot of money so let's just get him.
It doesn't hurt.
It doesn't hurt to have him.
Probably.
Zero.
Four.
And then, how do I use this?
Blows back many balloons.
Gains abilities.
Drops lives.
Cache crates and pick up and redeploy.
It's an ability.
Okay, okay.
Let's... I'm lazy so I just like to put them all on pursuit.
I'm not gonna lie.
Origin!
Thank you so much for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
Oh.
I'll do it.
Wait.
I'm glad everyone else can relate.
You can only do it mid-round?
Oh shoot.
Okay.
You.
And drop you.
Oh no.
I'll do it.
Do-do-do.
Oh, good.
Okay.
We still have him attached.
Oh no, what do I do?
Oh no, where do I put him?
Oh no!
I can put him here, no?
This still works kind of, no?
His range is really big.
So I think it will work, no?
No?
Yeah?
One more time!
There we go.
Wait, why didn't he move?
Oh, there he goes.
Okay.
Nice.
I'm flicking everything.
I'm flicking it all.
Glue bomb!
Yeah,
get pushed.
Get pushed.
The frames.
I know, it's so bad.
It's so bad, it's funny.
Nice.
Oh my gosh, almost a 20.
Almost a 20 rounds left.
This game is so demanding.
Time to upgrade my computer to NASA.
Move alchemist?
Yeah, but to where?
Nowhere to move him.
The frames.
The slowest game ever.
Is this how people usually play?
You play like this?
Yeah, I play Bloons.
Everyone needs a 50-80 for Bloons.
This game will surely be the one to set your PC on fire though.
Buy the snipers or the heli?
Okay.
The alchemist?
Because then he'll buff these guys, no?
Okay.
Oh, I have to do it mid-round.
Okay, here we go.
Oh, I have to make sure I click the right guy.
Oh, he'll only buff a couple.
Oh gosh.
Oh golly.
Everything is scaring me right now.
180!
I'm just gonna keep boosting my laser.
I'm boosting my laser.
I'm doing everything.
I'm clicking it all.
You.
Okay, nevermind.
Not you.
You?
It's not... It's like not...
For some reason.
Is one million gold possible in this run?
Oh, absolutely.
We're basically there.
We're basically there, no?
Please!
Nice.
A million!
I'm a millionaire!
That's me, mom!
I don't know why it doesn't like this one down here in the corner.
There we go.
It just really doesn't like to grab to let me press it.
I like that comment.
If you invest in better defense, it will be easier to get to round 200.
That's the game.
It's a defense game.
That's all you can do.
No!
It's so funny.
I don't think we'll be able to do that one.
It's a funny comment.
Wait, hold on.
Let me double check if my... Oh yeah, my meeting.
I'm asking.
Hot dog.
Thank you!
Thanks, Trine Princess.
Round 200 next stream?
Yeah, maybe.
Play muted while it streams?
Or while in the meeting?
Sorry I'm late.
I became a millionaire.
We might have to save it.
We're so close though.
We're so close.
Complimentary birthday, Supa.
It already passed on March 2nd though.
That's so long ago.
Where?
I was here.
First thing I did was hop on MGSV for the birthday cutscene.
Nana, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Nana.
Happy birthday!
I spent too much at the mint cafe.
Thank you.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Let's do one more round.
Who else can we add?
More...
More monkey pirates.
We'll do this one.
Bigger range.
More monkeys.
I'm sorry I'm late.
I'm becoming a millionaire.
I'm becoming the Bloons champion.
You can't blame me.
I'm a Bloons champion.
No one ever popped.
Oh, they actually know this one.
Attack faster.
Everybody, keep attacking.
And keep making money.
I don't think it's in range.
I hear the foam still.
You guys hear that?
Where does that thing drop?
Game is dying.
Check my bank.
It's fine.
I checked the bank.
I checked it.
It's okay.
Hello?
There we go.
Spoken like a real millionaire.
I know, right?
Go!
Oh, I could.
I could.
Attack faster!
Attack harder!
Oh my...
I was going to say minions, but make it like blinions.
My Bloon minions.
I can't save this.
I don't think I can save it.
I can't save it.
There we go.
Okay,
I'm being called upon.
I'm becoming... I'm being called upon.
Well guys, one more round.
One more round.
We can't end it.
We have to end it on 185, no?
Go!
We got this.
We're doing so well.
It's fine.
They understand.
I was popping off.
It's true.
I haven't even seen anything this round.
Monkey!
Thank you Weebsie for 4 months.
Kyle!
Thank you.
We're not well met.
That super chat reminded me that my birthday was on the 4th.
Solid Snake.
Okay, we'll do a nice birthday song and then I gotta go for real.
For real.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, Solid Snake0079.
Happy birthday.
By the way, your laugh is the best protector.
Maybe a nebulizer.
Maybe.
I do have something like that.
Next time.
Wait.
If I... Hold on.
How does it save?
If I just click home, will it save?
If I click home...
Do I have to exit out of the game completely?
I'm scared.
Yes?
Wait, I got an achievement.
Reveal 10,000 Bloons using Shimmer.
Neat.
I get monkey money.
Win a game in reverse mode.
Nice.
Wait.
How close are we to...
Still so many Bloons.
So many.
Okay.
I'll go play this combat.
But...
We didn't make it to our...
To our goal today.
But we're so close.
We're like so stinking close you guys.
We'll make it next time.
Thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
See you guys.
Bye bye.
Oh wait, I wanted to check real quick.
I'm scared.
Okay, save.
It's there, it's there, it's there.
Bye bye!